Lori Hernandez reveals where she'll put
the mirror ball trophy if she wins
Dancing with the Stars
the sixteen-year-old Olympian was a
guest on Tuesday nights jimmy kimmel
live where she told the host her plans
if she in fact wins the competition show
I think I'd want to put it in the center
of my house just so we could see it but
I'd have to ask my mom first mom's house
mom's rules oh really Jimmy admitted to
Laurie he spent a hefty amount that she
and Val will take the mirror ball home
let's say I don't know twenty five
hundred dollars on you to win the
dancing duo are clearly frontrunner on
the show and have also become very close
friends he's the coach I had Teddy there
he is the pro dancer has been there for
her during the passing of her
grandmother which we saw play out on
Monday night's show
ET spoke with laurie and vowel after
their emotional night how did you
possibly focus and get through that that
difficult difficult uh it was a little
rough but you know van I were able to
you know create this connection as
brother and sister through the past
couple weeks and you know at this point
I needed like one of my brothers I
needed family with me at the moment he
was there for me he helped pick me up so
um yeah dance it out